[Music]
woke up made coffee
number two performed extensive
fantasy-football research prior to
kick-off watch the Colts game looked at
porn watch movie four since video is
this a movie about bike messengers those
sins for since my DMC Zod isn't getting
his neck broken in this scene Todd isn't
getting his neck broken in this scene
got drunk and played video games finally
broke down and watched the Miley Cyrus
wrecking ball video porn wrote another
hate mail to my nemesis drove to
Starbucks
[Music]
got delicious iced coffee beverage can I
get it
she called me sweetie
she called me sweetie drove all
I got the eye of the tiger on your boobs
number three rewatch the Miley Cyrus
wrecking ball video to see if I missed
anything the first time we watch the
porn to see if I missed anything the
first time watch my cat Wallace chases
tail watch sister-wives fooled around
with the cinemasins rap song using my
rap app Bruce Willis kills little kids
worked on my Kevin Smith fan fiction
watched Breaking Bad and then in new
uses for the GoPro camera like golf club
cam masturbation cam answered emails
from fans
[Music]
that's from break I love my mama